so what say you to the carnivore diet  Enthusiast who is telling you that I've  been eating nothing but steak for the  last year and I feel fantastic well you  know we all know people who'd smoked two  packs of Marlboros for 90 years and are  fine but does that mean that cigarettes  do not increase your risk for lung  cancer of course not we know that fiber  is a main ingredient for creating a  healthy microbiome fiber and fermented  food now does it mean that there's not  room for animal protein on the plate no  it doesn't necessarily mean that there  are other reasons to avoid animal  protein there environmental reasons and  ethical reasons Etc but from a medical  lens it's making sure that there's  sufficient amounts of indigestible plant  fiber on the plate that is really the  most important element of that of course  you could be a carnivore your whole life  and somehow manage to be fine but you're  an N equal one number that is not a  scientific study make